[Musica]
[Applauso]
sto per trattare una questione tosta
dirò cose che probabilmente saranno
difficili da digerire ma necessarie e
per questo vi prego di porvi nella
condizione di riceverle e di elaborarle
partendo dal presupposto che il mio
unico obiettivo è quello di scoprire
degli aspetti della nostra società che
per troppo tempo sono stati nascosti
sotto un tappeto di illusione che noi
calpestiamo da decenni negli ultimi mesi
ho fatto decine e decine di interviste
perché ha lanciato un podcast che si
chiama razzismo made in italy che vi
consiglio di ascoltare slough di ball
perché è una sorta di guida
l'antirazzismo in tutte queste
interviste due domande non sono mai
mancate la prima è ci sono stati degli
effettivi miglioramenti da punti vista
del razzismo in italia dalla nascita tra
virgolette del movimento black light
smart ad oggi il movimento black la
smettere in realtà è nato negli stati
uniti intorno a 2013 1014 però in italia
è esploso esattamente un anno fa a
giugno 2020 quando le piazze di tutto il
mondo e molte piazze anche italiane si
sono riempite per protestare contro
l'abuso di potere negli stati uniti ma
anche contro il razzismo presente in
italia e me risposta è stata che
purtroppo questo risveglio delle
coscienze antirazzista e durato giusto
il tempo di postare il quadratino nero
su instagram so se vi ricordate l'anno
scorso che tutti volevamo acquistare il
quadratino nero per mostrare solidarietà
giusto il tempo di fare il self icall
cartellone black light smart in piazza
alla fine dell'estate finito tutto
a questa mia risposta segue la seconda
domanda ovvero quei farci degli esempi
quindi di qual è il tipo di razzismo che
le persone di colore termine che io non
sopporto sono nera non sono di colore ok
perché sono nera quando sono arrabbiata
quando sono triste quando sono felice
per persone che cambiano colore in base
all'umore e non sono le persone nere
quando mi pongono queste domande rimango
però di sasso perché me le fanno dei
giornalisti e giornaliste che io
suppongo legano i giornali italiani come
me nei quali quotidiamente no però
settimanalmente sono riportati casi di
razzismo fate una breve ricerca online
per verificare i casi di reati subiti
sono verificati in italia dall'inizio
dell'anno ad oggi troverete una lista
infinita e quindi mi domando ma perché
io ci metto poco a fare esempi di
razzismo tra virgolette all'italiana e
invece voi giornalisti giornalista e
bianchi no la risposta che mi sono posta
che mi sono data è che forse in italia
c'è una concezione di razzismo che è un
po antiquata razzismo come qualcosa di
irrazionale il razzismo come qualcosa
che è portato avanti da persone folli da
persone tra virgolette stupide da
persone ignoranti ma razzismo nel 2021
non può ancora essere associato
all'ignoranza significa essere persone
cieche
vi faccio degli esempi per farvi
comprendere che cosa intendo per meglio
che cosa si intende per razzismo
sistemico quando la razza lizzazione
ovvero i processi che categorizzano le
persone in base alla razza percepita
razza un termine che la lingua italiana
fa tantissima paura ma semplicemente
significa che la mia né rezza colore
della mia pelle
parla prima di me ok quindi quando io
occupo uno spazio le persone non pensano
a quello che dico non pensano quello che
io so fare
ma mi giudicano soltanto in base a
pregiudizi che hanno interiorizzato su
le persone a professioni del insieme ok
brava prova ok quindi la razza possiamo
anche la razza possiamo anche non
nominarla ma se di fatto io vengo
giudicata soltanto in base al colore
della mia pelle quindi per motivo
razziale capite che ha poco senso non a
nominarla quando la razza lizzazione
occupa diversi strati della società
esempio vado ad un colloquio di lavoro
prima ancora di poter entrare
nell'ufficio dell'imprenditore oppure
del responsabile di risorse umane vede
il mio curriculum c'è la mia foto o la
pelle nera
vengo scartata un curriculum dove non
c'è la foto il cognome non mi sembra
mica un cognome italiano scartiamo lo
perché prima gli italiani fisso un
appuntamento telefonico per poter
visitare un appartamento ovviamente
parlo italiano perfetto perché sono nate
e cresciute in italia il presidente
l'appuntamento con l'agente immobiliare
o con il proprietario dell'immobile e lì
la mia voce non o meglio l'associazione
della mia voce alla mia fisicità non
quadra perché la mia fisicità non è
associata nell'immaginario collettivo a
l'identità italiana e quindi l'immobile
non è più disponibile perché prima gli
italiani quando i mezzi di comunicazione
anziché condannare o perlomeno criticare
slogan nazionalisti slogan che dividono
se ci bombardano con prima gli italiani
succede che oneri diventiamo
desensibilizzati
dei sensibilizzate oppure che li
interiorizzano no e quindi se questi
slogan vengono interiorizzati da chi
occupa delle posizioni di potere da chi
ha la possibilità di distribuire dei
privilegi li capite che la
razionalizzazione il razzismo occupa
diverse aree della nostra società e non
è un caso che nei centri del 2018 emerso
che la 88 per cento delle famiglie
straniere o meglio scusate l'ottanta per
cento degli stranieri con regolare
permesso di soggiorno occupano le
nicchie a più alta densità di
sfruttamento di lavoro che soltanto ad
un lavoratore straniero su dieci è
concesso di ricoprire delle cariche con
un alto salario non è un caso che quando
andiamo in banca le persone non bianche
fanno i servizi di pulizia e invece chi
sta dietro la scrivania e quasi sempre
solo bianco per un caso che nelle scuole
le insegnanti gli insegnanti sono quasi
sempre bianchi e invece chi pulisce le
scuole sono persone non bianche
non è un caso che negli uffici pubblici
è raro vedere persone non è anche queste
non sono delle casualità
queste sono il frutto della applicazione
della razza lizzazione come metro di
come metro organizzativo dei vari
apparati che compongono la nostra
società
l'ultimo esempio che vorrei farvi che è
il più importante perché è quello che
connette il razzismo al capitalismo il
capitalismo ha creato la razza
lizzazione quindi la gerarchia delle
razze decidendo che quella che era in
fondo alla gerarchia era quella che si
poteva sfruttare no per ottenere dei
guadagni economici e oggigiorno il
razzismo è indissolubilmente collegato
al capitalismo tramite di meccanismi di
sfruttamento della forza lavoro che
minimizza i costi per massimizzare i
profitti e limitare la capacità di
difesa politica
le persone che sono razziali date come
nere e che quindi vengono sfruttate un
esempio è la sono le leggi che
regolamentano i flussi migratori europei
non so se vi ricordate che l'anno scorso
c'era si era parlato della sanatoria per
regolarizzare immigrati braccianti i
migranti le badanti e quindi tutte
quelle persone che svolgono dei lavori
considerati essenziali essenziali perché
per lo stato e quindi tuttora in realtà
ci sono delle leggi che fanno siti delle
persone siano legalmente presenti in
italia soltanto finché possono essere
sfruttate quindi non non viene presa in
considerazione la loro dignità umana
la loro umanità ma soltanto le loro
braccia la loro condizione di o meglio
la nostra condizione di necessità
un esempio lampante sono le donne
migranti quando tu sei una donna
immigrata afro discendente operaia e
come ho detto prima
siccome siamo la società razziali data
probabilmente occupano le le aree a più
alta densità di sfruttamento succede che
avere uno dei figli può essere un
problema quando vivo o meglio quando
lavora in un sistema che mi sfrutta con
degli orari assurdi 12 14 ore al giorno
io sono mamma e sono operare sulla
fornisce niente devo decidere se
accudire i miei figli oppure fare degli
straordinari al lavoro straordinari che
mi permettono però di poter stare
legalmente in italia perché se io non
guadagno abbastanza denaro non posso
rinnovare il permesso di soggiorno
capite che avere o meno delle risorse
economiche mi permette di assumere delle
baby sitter per accudire miei figli
mentre io sono al lavoro avere o meno la
pelle nera
significa andare al lavoro in maniera
armoniosa oppure no perché al momento in
cui io madre operaia migrante chiedo di
non essere sfruttata 12 14 ore al giorno
i miei figli le mie figlie vorrei anche
vedere e mi delle detto se le cose non
ti stanno bene tornatene a casa tua sai
quante ne trovo di operai e africane che
posso sfruttare quanto mi pare e quando
tutto questo sistema di sfruttamento
capitalista è legittimato da delle leggi
capite che non si può più far finta che
il razzismo sia soltanto una questione
di ignoranza
quando la razziali d'azione viene
utilizzata come meccanismo per
organizzare vari apparati della nostra
società il razzismo diventa sistemico e
razzismo diventa istituzionalizzato
quando io che sono nate cresciuta in
italia di vento cittadina italiana a 21
anni perché prima gli italiani ma di
sangue non gli italiani come me
ovviamente che sono nata e cresciuta qui
che non parla una lingua dei miei
genitori che non conosco nessun altra
cultura oltre a quella italiana mentre
una ragazza che è nata negli stati uniti
che d'italia conosce solo pasta e pizza
che non sana parla italiano ma altri
snodo italiano lei italiana si prima gli
italiani di sangue e questa concezione
della cittadinanza basata su un criterio
selettivo di sangue risale ai primi anni
del novecento parliamo di prima della
nascita del fascismo capite che è
qualcosa che è non solo alla cronistico
ma che è agghiacciante
il sangue che ti scorre tra le vene vale
di più delle caratteristiche che
rappresentano quella che l italianità ma
concludendo che cosa possiamo fare
quindi noi persone che occupiamo
il sistema italiano la società italiana
la prima cosa che possiamo fare è quella
di educarci informarci iniziare a
guardare la società con un occhio
critico iniziare a guardare
quali sono le discriminazioni che
subiscono delle altre persone che cosa
viene tolto a loro e in base a chi in
base a quale motivo i migranti non è che
fanno gli operai perché non sono
intelligenti
sapete quanti migranti hanno dei titoli
di studio hanno le lauree ma le loro
laura non meno noi conosciute
questo non è un caso no quindi
informarsi guardare con occhio critico
la società allargare la propria cerchia
di conoscenze
se tutti gli spazi che occupate hanno
soltanto persone simili a voi fate delle
domande perché noi siamo portati ad
approcciarci a persone che ci ispirano
fiducia a persone con cui magari abbiamo
qualcosa in comune però non è possibile
contribuire alla lotta anti razzista
se non si hanno delle relazioni con
persone che razzismo lo subiscono in
prima persona e infine cercare di fare
proprie le battaglie di quei gruppi che
in italia ancora vengono marginalizzati
senza nessun motivo e senza un criterio
logico perché l'italia non può dirsi un
paese antirazzista fino a che discrimina
delle categorie di persone soltanto
perché hanno avuto la sfortuna di
nascere nel paese sbagliato tutte le
persone dovrebbero poter godere di
diritti fondamentali di essere ritenute
e trattate come persone umane come
esseri umani indipendentemente dal fatto
che siano straniere o che abbiano un dna
italiano grazie